i
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález desde el
comienzo de la invasión y la guerra en
ucrania por parte de las tropas rusas la
comunidad internacional ha intentado
entender cuál es la posición que tiene
china frente a este conflicto llama
mucho la atención que en el consejo de
seguridad de la onu china ha evitado
condenar a rusia por esta invasión y en
algunos escenarios se ha ofrecido
incluso como una especie de mediador
varios aliados occidentales entre ellos
eeuu han especulado sobre la posibilidad
de que china asista en materia militar a
rusia para avanzar con sus planes de
invasión en el territorio ucraniano
precisamente dmitri peskov quien es el
portavoz del gobierno ruso negó que su
país haya pedido ayuda a china
igualmente la embajada de china ante el
gobierno italiano en la ciudad de roma
negó los señalamientos y acusó a eeuu de
desinformar contra este país veamos
el encuentro del xi jinping con vladimir
putin hace apenas un mes fue una
oportunidad para que ambos líderes
firmaran una asociación sin límites
según si más fuerte que una alianza
rusia se ha convertido en el país más
sancionado del mundo pero beijing se ha
negado a condenar rotundamente la
invasión y no ha impuesto ninguna
sanción a moscú nos oponemos firmemente
a las sanciones
el día de la invasión china levantó las
restricciones a las importaciones de
trigo ruso el gigante asiático no solo
quiere más trigo sino también más
materias primas e hidrocarburos lo que
es una buena noticia para rusia putin
también llegó a un acuerdo para
suministrar gas a china a través de un
segundo gasoducto llamado poder de
siberia 2 el primer conducto que conectó
a los dos países se puso en marcha justo
después de que rusia anexar a crimea y
entró en funcionamiento en 2019 mientras
tanto los negocios entre ambos países
continúan como de costumbre esta es la
página web oficial de los productos
rusos que se venden en china ahora todo
está agotado
hoy estoy muy contenta he recibido mis
pedidos mira todo esto son productos
rusos
en este complicado contexto
internacional vemos que podemos contar
con nuestro viejo amigo china
china alivia los daños económicos de las
sanciones internacionales a moscú pero
con cierta cautela por ejemplo desde la
exclusión de los bancos rusos del
sistema swift los bancos chinos
a su rescate
si hay algún tipo de interés por parte
de china cuáles pueden ser qué papel
quiere tener el presidente si jinping en
esta crisis internacional puede ser o la
neutralidad o tomar una posición más
clara que tanto podría involucrarse el
país asiático muchos ven a china como el
mediador perfecto para poder solucionar
esta crisis en ucrania en el marco de
esta guerra que rumbo pueden tener
también las relaciones entre beijing y
washington unas relaciones que ya de por
sí son bastante tensas hoy en el debate
de france 24 analizamos el papel que ha
jugado china el gran aliado de rusia en
esta guerra que ha destruido ya a varias
ciudades ucranianas y que ha provocado
el éxodo de más de dos millones de
personas desde el territorio ucraniano
hacia países vecinos y otros puntos de
europa para analizar este tema saludamos
a constanza a jorquera ella es analista
internacional e investigadora del centro
de estudios coreanos y núcleo de
estudios asiáticos de la universidad de
santiago en chile y en bogotá en
colombia está con nosotros conectada a
esta conversación linda luna ella es
sinóloga internacionalista es también de
la universidad externado en la ciudad de
bogotá en colombia ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en este debate con sus comentarios y sus
preguntas lo pueden hacer a través de
las redes sociales no se encuentran en
facebook en instagram y también en
twitter estamos como arroba france24
guión bajo es santi logo que es mi
cuenta personal les recuerdo el numeral
efe 24 es nuestra etiqueta para que
usted pueda dejar todos los comentarios
relacionados con este tema comienza
entonces por darle la bienvenida a
constanza en la ciudad de santiago en
chile y quiero comenzar poniendo en
contexto a los televidentes constanza y
lina también comencemos por entender
cómo son las relaciones entre rusia y
china- estos dos países que tienen una
frontera común y una historia ligada en
diferentes aspectos cuál es el contexto
de estas relaciones
bueno las relaciones entre china y rúsia
siempre han sido complejas son aliados
naturales aunque tenemos que el contexto
del cisma o la ruptura sino soviética en
su momento pero desde el fin de la
guerra fría vuelven a esta podríamos ir
posición de aliados naturales porque
también representan una contraposición
respecto al orden internacional liberal
liderado por eeuu entonces no olvidemos
que está el contexto de los brics y
otros esquemas de cooperación donde se
muestran muy cercanos la idea es generar
un frente común podríamos decir contra
eeuu aunque china se ha ido moderando
hay cautelosa en ese sentido y lina su
opinión contexto la relación entre moscú
y beijing para terminar armar este
rompecabezas y ponerlo como punto de
partida de este debate este análisis
bueno si en ese sentido hay que aclarar
de hecho que tanto putin como bueno de
hecho el principio del shooting y
corbacho y después su team con hu jintao
luego consiguen bing los dos
establecieron que tenía que ser muy
claro que lo de rusia y china no es una
alianza porque una alianza requeriría
entonces que todos mis amigos son tus
amigos y todos mis enemigos son tus
enemigos y esa no es el tipo de relación
que tienen china y rusa y la relación
que tienen es de socios estratégicos
integrales
eso significa que da espacio para estar
de acuerdo y en desacuerdo en ciertos
temas es importante tener en cuenta que
es una relación que fue intensa que tuvo
momentos de cercanía y lejanía a partir
de la ideología pero que después de la
caída del muro de berlín y de la guerra
fría se consolidar una relación más
enfocada a tres temas específicos un
tema es que tanto china como rusia se
enfocaron más en el desarrollo comercial
y económico y eso llevó a decidió no
usar la relación en segundo lugar las
dos estaban de acuerdo en que para
mantener ese es el modelo funcionando
era necesario tener una asia pacífica y
eso significaba tener menor influencia
de los países hegemónicos en asia y el
tercer punto que termina siendo un punto
en común de rossi china no depende de
ellos depende más de el ataque de
occidente hacia las ideas de china
entonces en el 2014 crimea luego no sé
de todos los temas con taiwán y demás
pues han marcado que necesariamente se
vean al mismo lado de un conflicto pero
no significa que la alianza sea
integrada y completa línea continuó con
usted para hacer la ronda a la inversa
en el contexto en el que estamos un poco
más de dos semanas de guerra en ucrania
después de una invasión de las tropas
rusas por el este del país y vemos cómo
han ido avanzando y poco a poco van
acercando aquí que es la capital
ucraniana que papel desde su análisis y
de acuerdo a los hechos que hemos visto
a lo largo de estos últimos días qué
papel está jugando china a nivel
internacional en este conflicto cuál es
su análisis
si no está siendo totalmente coherente
con su política exterior la política
exterior de china tiene como principio
fundamental el respeto a los sabor de
mía de los países eso está en términos
de hecho es decir no invadir un país
como también en términos de no hacer
bloqueos económicos y cosas de ese
estilo porque violaría la soberanía del
país
entonces ese principio china lo está
respetando y eso no significa es decir
china está evitando ponerse en esa
dualidad en la que nos quieren poner
globalmente que eso eres bueno eres malo
estás a favor de rusia el malo o estás a
favor de la otan y eeuu es bueno si no
quieres salirse de ese debate porque no
sólo chinas sino muchos países asiáticos
estar en una complejidad total en una
paradoja terrible porque quieren tener
buenas relaciones con eeuu y con rusia y
no quieren tener que tomar partido en
una bipolaridad en este sentido china ha
dicho cuatro cosas fundamentales en
torno a este conflicto primero
y ninguna excusa justifica
violar la soberanía de otro país
entonces no está diciendo directamente a
rusia invadir este ucrania pero si está
diciendo que no está de acuerdo por lo
que pasó y de hecho ha dicho claramente
que cree que rusia exagero no en su
acción contra ucrania en segundo lugar
dice que es excelente amigos de rusia y
de ucrania razón por la cual no va a
dañar por sus relaciones con ninguno de
los dos por lo tanto no se va a sumar a
los
embargos económicos ni nada por el
switch y tercero se ofrece como mediador
en unas condiciones muy específicas
entre esa es la condición de la
seguridad indivisible
constanza su opinión sobre el papel que
está jugando china en este conflicto
internacional puede añadir y
complementar lo que ha dicho el inah y
explicarnos su punto de vista por
supuesto
si estoy perfectamente de acuerdo es
plenamente coherente y viene a reforzar
los cinco principios de la coexistencia
pacífica que se aplican cierto no
solamente entender la política exterior
de china separada de una estrategia de
seguridad más amplia están unidas bien y
en ese sentido claramente hay un intento
previo por parte de china de acercarse
no solamente a europa como unidad
general sino que también a europa del
este y europa central como socio cierto
entablando mayor cercanía en los
contextos de proyectos de modernización
y desarrollo de infraestructura y
gobernanza global por parte de china en
este sentido lo que hace rusia
finalmente es poner a china entre la
espada y la pared pero como bien decía
la colega
pienso que ofrecerse como mediador y que
ya está teniendo conversaciones con
potencias europeas puede finalmente
mover cierto la balanza de un
protagonismo mayor hacia china en
términos de negociaciones
internacionales no olvidemos que son los
países europeos en general tienen ese
perfil y china- al consolidar eso puede
seguir legitimando se como un tomador de
decisiones y como garante del
multilateralismo en el sistema
internacional que es un rol sobre toda
potencia hegemónica puede cumplir
constanza pero esta posición que estamos
viendo que usted nos explica que podría
tomar china como una especie de mediador
también acercándose a países europeos es
una posición iniciativa de beijing o
beijing y bueno china está respondiendo
a la presión internacional que la
comunidad internacional está obligando
este país a que tome una posición en
este conflicto así como nos explicaba
lina que nos están mostrando dos caras
de la moneda que tenemos que estar del
lado de la otan y al lado eeuu como los
buenos de la película o del lado de los
rusos que invadieron el territorio
ucraniano como los malos
comunidad internacional poniendo bajo
presión a china para que tome una
postura en este conflicto en particular
en mi opinión sí
en un principio no olvidemos que también
china está saliendo de los juegos
olímpicos de invierno que también en
términos diplomáticos es importante es
más bien la comunidad internacional la
que está llamando a china a tomar una
posición mucho más explícita y en verdad
china tiene mucho que perder de esta
crisis y no maneja sus piezas con
cuidado entonces hay que tener en cuenta
la racionalidad de china en este sentido
porque como bien habíamos conversado
rusia y china- no tienen intereses
perfectamente alineados entonces más
bien esto es una prueba de fuego
podríamos decir de que tan madura está
china como una potencia global capaz de
aportar en la discusión y de resolver
crisis internacionales de esta
envergadura entonces el hecho de
mantener un bajo perfil y mantenerse
lejos de esto también se ve interpelado
no solamente en la mediación como tal
sino que también en las votaciones
cierto en el consejo de seguridad el
tema de tratar de mantenerse lo más
cauteloso posible pero al mismo tiempo
demostrar un pragmatismo respecto a cómo
poder servir menos afectados la
situación
linas y china toma una posición ya sea
mantenerse un poco neutral digámoslo así
en cuanto a la situación en ucrania no
expresar ningún tipo de opinión y no
estar ni del lado de eeuu a europa o de
rusia que está perdiendo o poniendo en
riesgo china al no tomar una posición
clara en este conflicto entre ellas
creería yo y lo pongo sobre la mesa
usted me dirá si si es así está
precisamente esa relación con moscú y en
un momento en el que moscú pues
prácticamente está basando toda su
energía de proyección internacional a
través de la ayuda que le puede dar
beijing en la parte económica y política
bueno pues precisamente china si está
tomando una postura clara lo que pasa es
que no es la postura que nosotros
quisiéramos pues
dual en ese sentido china ha dicho
claramente que es lo que está esperando
este conflicto cuando se ofrece como
mediadora está diciendo que lo necesario
es de es escalar el conflicto lo más
pronto posible y en ese sentido está
invitando a países incluido eeuu a veces
escalar el conflicto no es decir no
echarle más leña al fuego como decimos
acá en colombia sino que ayudar a que se
descargue el conflicto para terminar con
la guerra que es totalmente indeseable
en ese sentido como decía la compañera
la colega que estoy totalmente de
acuerdo si no está mostrando cuál se de
cuál es su estilo de rolen en términos
de liderazgo internacional y su estilo
no lo está mostrando como un estilo de
mediador si en ese sentido china puede
velar por múltiples intereses al tiempo
y cuando ya proponen el concepto de
seguridad indivisible lo que nos está
diciendo es que no podemos arreglar este
conflicto si no tenemos en cuenta la
seguridad de todos no solamente de
europa no solamente de la percepción de
eeuu no solamente de ucrania sino
también la seguridad de rusia la
seguridad de china y la seguridad de
asia es decir no podemos considerar que
una seguridad es y ahora más válida que
la otra y que solo desde ese punto de
partida sí dándoles a todos una validez
iguales que se pueden hacer diálogos que
lleguen a una seguridad cooperativa y
estable en largo plazo entonces creo que
hay dos opciones si quieres llegar a
caer ante la presión internacional que
no creo que sea el caso de tomar una
postura más rígida pues en este caso
podría verse afectada sus relaciones o
con rusia o con eeuu dependiendo de la
postura que tomen pero creo que el china
no va a caer en eso y que más bien vamos
a encontrarnos con un nuevo tipo de
liderazgo internacional muy enfocado a
la multilateralidad y a la masa un tema
de
diálogos y diplomacia y de escalamiento
del conflicto que esta estancia
operativo e interesante línea continuó
con usted esa falta de posición como
dicen muchos o esa posición como usted
explica que es distinta a la que se
espera desde el lado de los países de
occidente tiene una posición muy
diferente a la que está tomando beijing
y que tanta incertidumbre puede generar
en el tema comercial en el tema
económico cuando el mundo está tratando
de recuperarse después de los meses de
confinamiento de la pandemia kobe 19 y
de una realidad que es inevitable y es
que el mundo entero se mueve a través
del comercio con china es un importante
jugador en el comercio internacional
esto podría generar entonces
incertidumbre de problemas económicos a
gran escala a nivel mundial si si
occidente no entiende la lectura de
beijing en cuanto a la posición que tome
bueno en ese sentido la postura de china
es coherente con dos cosas una un
embargo económico nunca ha cambiado una
situación ahí sigue de corea del norte
ahí sigue venezuela ahí sigue cuba es
decir el embargo económico aprobado que
no es un mecanismo suficiente para
cambiar una situación entonces en ese
sentido no tiene por qué sumarse pero
además chinas conscientes que estamos en
un mundo profundamente globalizado donde
este embargo económica rusia va a
afectar al mundo entero no solamente a
rusia y en ese sentido china no quiere
sumarse a eso y por eso es que se rehúsa
a embargar económicamente a moscú y por
eso es que además le dice a ucrania que
seguirá con sus relaciones comerciales
con ucrania como bien enciende en este
sentido es claro que el sistema
internacional económico está viéndose
amenazado en este momento por estas por
éstas pues por estas actitudes hacia
rusia que nos van a terminar en el largo
plazo castigando sólo a rusia sino
también al mundo que desde esa
perspectiva la postura de china es
tratar de cuidar
los plazos comerciales internacionales
para que la economía internacional no
caiga
constanza regreso con ustedes y en la
ciudad de santiago en chile para
preguntarle puntualmente por la relación
entonces entre moscú y beijing pero
desde la óptica del beneficio que pueda
tener el kremlin que necesita en este
momento moscú de china más allá de
simplemente tener el apoyo internacional
o como lo ha dicho eeuu sin mostrar
algún tipo de evidencia que ha
solicitado ayuda militar que tanto
necesita entonces moscú de beijing
bueno como lo habíamos visto en las
imágenes al inicio claramente
rusia se ve beneficiado de que china sea
la gran potencia promotora del
multilateralismo además de mantener
cierto subiendo los recursos los
acuerdos el comercio también tener
acceso a los mercados no olvidemos la
importancia del mercado chino a nivel
interno y de también tener acceso a
cooperación de otro tipo estamos
hablando de cooperación militar o lo que
se llama operaciones de segundo orden el
repaso de ayuda humanitaria
esta ayuda humanitaria temas de
protección civil y de evacuación y otras
tecnologías no solamente si no la está
enviando a ucrania sino que también la
está ofreciendo a rusia entonces
finalmente es el único país o potencia
confiable a la cual puede recurrir y en
ese sentido vemos que cada vez rusia se
está quedando más sola porque como
habíamos visto al principio de hecho
china ha declarado a través del ministro
de relaciones exteriores de que esto no
es un conflicto qué le corresponda a
china entonces también se está
distanciando entonces en ese sentido
pienso que
también hay que tener en cuenta como
rusia se puede apoyar en china algo que
se promueve mucho respecto a la
diplomacia del guerrero luego de
promover esta narrativa podríamos decir
algo anti occidental y culpar a eeuu y
la otan como por escalar e inflamar
estas tensiones entonces es importante a
nivel de relaciones comerciales de
relaciones estratégicas y también en
términos de comunicacional es cierto de
diplomacia pública y diplomacia cultura
constanza continuó con usted para
preguntarle por un tema que han
mencionado ustedes a lo largo del
programa y es el multilateralismo está
ventana que nos muestra china en cuanto
a la forma de relacionarse con el resto
de los países en el marco de este
conflicto en ucrania estamos hablando de
una especie de nuevo orden a nivel
internacional dada esta coyuntura la
guerra en ucrania estamos saliendo o
intentando salir de la pandemia de kobe
19 y china sigue teniendo cifras
altísimas de crecimiento pese a que
estaba confinado con algunas ciudades
por por los casos de kobe 19 este multar
al multilateralismo
lo vio usted como que está en una fase
inicial o que estos son unos primeros
pasos que da china y que lo podemos ver
más adelante proyectado desde otros
países a nivel internacional
bueno el tema del multilateralismo es
algo que la promovió consistentemente
finalmente son las reglas del fuego y la
arquitectura del sistema internacional
actual lo que ha permitido que china
venda y se convierta en la potencia
económica global que hoy en este sentido
en cuanto a la pandemia también fue
interpelada tiempo y fue el país que más
promueve esta idea de mantener el
comercio abierto haciendo de mantener la
cooperación y en ese sentido se estima
que ya se viene dando hace bastante
tiempo yo diría que se aceleró esta
identidad o este protagonismo que ha
tomado sin nada participe la guerra
comercial con eeuu nuevo con el manejo
de la pandemia cierto y también el mismo
precio esto es para el equipo de los
líderes veamos cómo se ha promovido el
tema de lakers de la rumba el señor tino
el destino de la humanidad ha compartido
o sea ya hace usted que en este sentido
si tenemos ahora el tema de los
conflictos vemos vemos que esta
oportunidad esta idea que viene hace
bastante tiempo un piso de cómo se mueve
el desde el atlántico hasta el pacífico
linda quiero conocer su opinión en torno
a este tema al multilateralismo un nuevo
orden que se está construyendo a partir
de lo que nos ofrece china en materia de
relacionamiento entre los países cuál es
su opinión si china
privilegia al multilateralismo como
mecanismo para mantener la armonía y la
paz internacional en ese sentido china
nos está proponiendo o sea china tiene
doble postura en el multilateralismo por
un lado con vélez con el andamiaje
internacional existente es decir cumple
con lo ya existente pero ofrece
alternativas multilaterales para ajustar
asuntos que china considera necesarios
por ejemplo el primer asunto es una
democratización del sistema
internacional en el sentido que las
instituciones tradicionales suelen
favorecer a unos sobre otros entonces
china intenta promover organizaciones
donde todos puedan sentarse en
condiciones de igual a igual
independientemente del tamaño de las
economías también instituciones que
promuevan una distribución del
desarrollo más equitativa a nivel
internacional lo cual es evidente por
ejemplo con la franja y la ruta pero
también con el banco brics por ejemplo y
en términos de asia pues está el consejo
de seguridad de shanghai no que en este
momento nos muestra también una visión
muy distinta de la seguridad porque no
es como una contraparte de la otan sino
es la seguridad de asia central vista
desde una postura multidimensional que
contrastado con esa postura digamos más
de defensa de la otan
lina continuó con usted para preguntarle
por un punto importante y es tal vez uno
de los grandes temores que tiene
occidente particularmente
eeuu la casa blanca teme que este guión
que estamos viendo por parte de rusia en
ucrania en el este de ucrania que
también ya vimos de forma similar en
georgia hace unos años atrás pueda verse
desde el lado chino con respecto a
taiwán un territorio que beijing reclama
como parte de su territorio pero que a
nivel internacional es reconocido por
varios países como un estado
independiente diferente a la república
popular de china aquí se está generando
tensión entre washington y beijing que
puede pasar allí china invadir taiwán
bueno estos temas se unen pero no por el
lugar que todo el mundo cree mucha gente
a veces piensa que china va a aprovechar
esta oportunidad para invadir y taiwán
pero la postura de china frente a taiwán
es muy
cautelosa porque taiwán es un tema
complejo y lo último que quiere china es
verse involucrada en un asunto de osh en
una guerra militar que podría después
debilitar las muchos otros aspectos la
naturaleza del conflicto de clanes the
time and son muy distintos sin embargo
si hay unos puntos que es interesante
tener en cuenta es que lo mismo que han
hecho la otan pero sobre todo eeuu en
ucrania lo está haciendo también en
taiwán no les ha vendido más de 800
millones de dólares en misiles está
entrenando militares en taiwán está
promoviendo un discurso separatista de
taiwán entonces en ese sentido pareciera
como que se quisiera forzar a china a
encontrarse también en un conflicto con
taiwán
en términos digamos de historia cuando
se reconoce en la hormona el 71 que
china es la es el país y no taiwán el
mundo ya había tomado una decisión al
respecto pero es más la presión
internacional la que genera una tensión
que china quiere evitar porque sabe
tiene claro que ese es su gran talón de
aquiles y que sería un tema bastante
complejo y constanza a su opinión sobre
este tema de taiwán que genera tanta
preocupación a nivel de occidente y
particularmente a eeuu que ya ha
reiterado en varias ocasiones que hará
lo posible y lo que está a su alcance
para defender a esta isla allí en el mar
de china meridional
si también estoy de acuerdo con la
colega porque hay una narrativa
occidental muy propia de la amenaza
china promovida por eeuu hace bastante
tiempo de que el conflicto es inevitable
me refiero un conflicto de tipo clásico
miel y en ese sentido el caso de ucrania
con rusia es perfecto para empujar esa
narrativa respecto a taiwán da igual no
es igual ucrania las relaciones no son
las mismas no no es lo mismo hablar de
un espacio pos-soviético donde se
encuentre ucrania que en el caso de que
da igual donde se aplican otros
principios efectivamente china no está
en condiciones cierto de poder enfrentar
un conflicto de estas características
que inmediatamente estaría global entre
las potencias más importantes del mundo
efectivamente es más asertiva con taiwán
vemos que cuando se cumplen los cien
años de del partido comunista cierto y
se ha visto que hay más vuelos como
donde se sobrevuela el espacio de
defensa aérea de taiwán taiwán anunció
que va a aumentar su presupuesto y su
capacidad
defensa esos es claramente esa atención
es gigante se ve pero
efectivamente no están las condiciones
vemos pienso que china también viendo
esta situación de rusia con ucrania se
da cuenta lo peligroso y lo costoso que
es emprender este tipo de campaña y
estrategia respecto a este tipo de
territorios entonces no veo que este
intento de absorción de empujar un
conflicto sea posible en el corto y
mediano plazo para demás que
históricamente lo que hemos visto es que
la principal extra estrategia de china
es expandir la influencia internacional
de este país a través de acuerdos
económicos o inversiones en
infraestructura lo vemos en áfrica lo
vemos en américa latina y no por el lado
bélico que es lo que está esperando la
comunidad internacional que pueda
reaccionar en algún momento constanza
usted menciona una palabra clave en todo
este tema de la guerra que se vive en el
donbass y que involucra a estos países
de peso internacional y es la narrativa
aquí entre washington moscú y beijing se
está dando también una guerra
informativa hay muchísima desinformación
y china- varias veces señalado a eeuu de
estar desinformado precisamente con esto
del pedido del supuesto pedido de rusia
por un apoyo militar por parte de china
es algo que eeuu no ha podido mostrar
evidencias claras pero beijing ya lo ha
señalado como parte de la campaña de
desinformación pero china también ha
hecho lo propio ha hecho lo mismo a
través de sus medios públicos esta
campaña hasta donde nos podría llevar
que análisis hace usted esta dialéctica
de esta narrativa mediática
bueno aquí hay varios elementos de
varios niveles porque claramente uno de
los temas importantes en cualquier
conflicto y en las relaciones internas
internacional es el tema de los
imaginarios y el manejo de la opinión
pública claramente los medios
occidentales y estadounidenses son muy
poderosos hoy son los que empujan una
cierta visión internacional mientras que
medios que están más ligados al estado
cierto en el caso de china e incluso
entre en rusia cierto responden también
no solamente a la visión internacional
que tienen de ellos sino que también de
su propia opinión pública a nivel
interno también está la dimensión del
uso de redes sociales y de las
plataformas digitales es cierto donde es
muy distinto a lo que estamos
acostumbrados en occidente vemos que
también los portavoces del ministerio de
relaciones exteriores chino y otras
autoridades diplomáticas han hecho lo
suyo cierto a través de redes sociales
sobre todo twitter de expresar sus ideas
de también empujar una narrativa de
mostrar a eeuu como hipócrita y que
efectivamente ha causado y promovió esta
belicosidad cierto en el mundo y está
también tomando una posición yo diría
que hay que tener cuidado con llamarla
antioccidental sino que también de
reivindicar cierto algunos temas
importantes en el claro de china como el
tema humillación de recuperar su estatus
etcétera entonces vamos a ver que estas
plataformas también son un espacio
crítico de hecho las estrategias
militares de china parece ser
ciberespacio también a un espacio
crítico y las comunicaciones también
como las conocemos claro y línea su
opinión sobre este tema de la crisis de
la desinformación y la propaganda que
han hecho también los gobiernos eeuu
china y rusia a través de las redes
sociales y sus canales informativos
aquí hay varios puntos no claramente los
medios de comunicación es en otro
escenarios la información son otro
escenario de guerra entonces es otra
forma de desinformar o de mantener una
imagen como la que hablábamos al
principio los buenos los malos estos
invaden esto es normal
e incluso de hipocresía y doble moral no
si nos damos cuenta en términos de lo
que se ha dicho antes de países como
china u otros que controlan la
información o bloquean google o cosas
por el estilo pero ahora youtube está
bloqueando rusia no en todas partes
entonces un poco depende de quién lo
haga lo percibimos como bueno o malo
pero es un hasta una estrategia normal
en este caso sin de repente importe
interesante porque por un lado la
desinformación es por parte de occidente
o de eeuu en particular está enfocada a
tratar de involucrar a china de forma
más directa al conflicto así como que de
alguna manera aparezca que china es
aliada fundamental de rusia y que china
también sabía de los ataques que les
iban a ocurrir en ucrania y excederá
etcétera lo cual china ha negado de
muchas formas pero por la parte china
también como dice la colega que estoy de
acuerdo también no es un tema anti
occidente pero sí es un tema de por
favor dejen de inventar cosas y dejen de
echarle leña al fuego de nuevo no pero a
la vez respondan por cosas como por
ejemplo la de los posibles laboratorios
de de eeuu en ucrania
entonces es más una intención de tratar
de develar que hay una estrategia más
profunda y una estrategia más grande que
no vemos detrás del conflicto de la
guerra y que es una estrategia global
probablemente liderada desde occidente
línea constancia me queda un minuto de
programa para hacer las conclusiones
rápidamente qué va a suceder con china
en este conflicto en este escenario
internacional a futuro no hay bola de
cristal no tenemos las cartas para
saberlas pero desde su análisis que
puede suceder al comienzo con constanza
bueno me parece que china va a continuar
así espero que se mantenga cautelosa a
proporcionar apoyo material sobre todo a
rusia porque esto tendría un impacto
cierto en el resultado de las
hostilidades en ucrania pero sí va a
tener impacto significativo en las
relaciones de china con occidente pienso
como había dicho anteriormente que es
una una prueba importante pienso que va
a continuar con este apoyo de segundo
orden cierto de promover la estabilidad
internacional garantizar que la economía
siga funcionando de prestar ayuda
humanitaria ya etcétera cómo mantener
este perfil de actor responsable de
cualquier distanciarse eeuu y de rusia y
su línea su opinión para el cierre
si por ese lado no creo que china vaya a
permitir que la presión internacional la
involucre de una manera
difícil al conflicto no creo que le vaya
a dar ayuda habilitará a rusia tampoco
creo que se va a mantener como 'the como
mediadora como promotora de ese
escalamiento del conflicto y también va
a poner muchos esfuerzos y que no caiga
el sistema internacional
mantenga puesto fin a constanza muchas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros en
el programa aquí en el debate de france
24 ustedes pueden seguir con nuestra
programación
[Música]